[Music]
welcome back to the big weekend show
it's time now for the big weekend flops
our picks for the biggest fails of the
week I'll go first the Border crisis
hits a new record sources telling Fox
News more than 260,000 border
apprehensions took place this month
that's the biggest monthly total ever on
record and I can attest to that I mean I
spend a good portion of my time at the
border been covering the border for
nearly 20 years and I've been there when
I've seen thousands of people come
across and what we're seeing now at the
border is unheard of and I want you to
think about all the people that got away
these are the apprehensions these don't
even include the numbers of people that
made it into the country that were never
apprehended or never had an encounter
with the border of Patrol and and the
border patrol down there they're
completely overwhelmed they they are not
getting the support that they need and
now they're potentially going to start
working without pay if there was to be a
government shutdown I mean we just have
such a lack of of respect for the border
patrol and they're working so hard for
us it's really upsetting
absolutely all right well to something a
little bit more important here this is
where we are in 2023 seemingly half
naked woman spotted waiting for her
flight on Spirit Airlines in Fort
Lauderdale this week looks like she
forgot to pack uh looks like she forgot
to pack pants she doesn't have pants on
she she's not wearing pants her butt is
hanging out you know I thought it was
Walmart where we go to see this crazy
stuff there's like accounts to go look
it up people at Walmart walking around
but now it's Spar Airlines it's it's the
it's the Airlines and the airports I
don't even know what the world's coming
to it's too bad she didn't have an
emotional support animal to cover her up
and then she would have been just fine
well I mean a week ago going to the
Senate that would have been acceptable
when they took away their dress code for
a little bit no shirt no shoes no
problem but no pants is also not a
problem pants I don't I don't know
listen I I just I got I got to bring my
daughter to the airport don't make her
don't make me explain things to her
she's not old enough to learn about
Jason what you got uh a New York City
professor who threatened to chop a New
York Post reporter with a machete this
is a real bad story has landed a new
teaching gig at a Swanky private college
in another instance she was caught in
video cursing out and threatening a
group of pro-life students so you
threaten somebody with their life you
take a machete to somebody's throat and
then they Greenlight you and hire you at
a new school to teach kids do you guys
remember this she turns the table over
on those kids and like and then so
Reporter Goes to interview about what
she did and she comes to the door like
I'm going to cut you well this is
because we have district attorneys that
don't want to bring charges against
anyone and people are getting away with
this all across the country but the
crazy thing is who's the school that
hired yeah that thank you that is the
question I want why aren't we bringing
attention the school that feels that
this is a good fit to educate our
children our education system is already
in the crapper as it is right now like
this is who we're bringing in for our
children I don't think so I'm pretty
sure that lady at the airport was a
professor too I'm not sure okay possible
well the GOP Le Select subcommittee is
now alleging Dr Anthony fouchy had a
secret meeting with the CIA about the
origins of Co 19 in a letter on Tuesday
to the Department of Health Congressman
Brad wstr of Ohio claimed Dr fouchy
played a role in the agency's review of
the origins of the pandemic and was
invited to agency headquarters to
participate in the probe but that's not
the most concerning part of this the
there is a whistleblower actually saying
that that there are some people who said
you know we don't we think that it could
possibly have been a lab leak Theory but
they were offered monetary compensation
to change their votes now again this is
you know not confirmed but I I'm very
very interested to see how this turns
out because if that is true I mean well
they lied to the American people look I
mean you know Senator ramp Paul has done
a stellar job of trying to bring this to
the Forefront and I believe that you
know Dr Anthony fouchi has a lot of
we're gonna have a lot to say about this
I need you guys to tune in tomorrow
because we might even get to talk about
this more but I just want to give you a
reminder you can catch us on X that used
to be Twitter Facebook it's at Big
Weekend show and Instagram at Big
Weekend show fnc hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else